so as we head into 2021 today's day one
if you listen to the last podcast right
before new year's we talked about goal
setting this year we're going to not
set up a bunch of goals we're not going
to set up a bunch of resolutions that
i'm going to lose 30 pounds and i'm
going to run four marathons and i'm
going to get a job and make this much
money
we're not gonna do that this year we're
gonna go deeper than that we're gonna
talk about who we are gonna be
and so i'm just gonna be open and be
vulnerable here i'm gonna let you know
here's what mine are
and a couple of these i'm gonna explain
them how they work right
so this year surprisingly not to my
third grade english teacher but to
everyone else on earth
my employers too we had a best-selling
book right this
the anxiety redefining anxiety hit the
best seller list
it surprised all of us it is sold 10
times plus
more copies than we were expecting right
so my goal for 21 2021 is not to
sell a certain number of books that's
not the goal
my goal isn't to um
my goal isn't to make another
best-seller list no
my goal of 20 20 21 is to
be somebody who is a writer
what does that mean that means this year
in 2020 i wrote speeches
a tiny little book letters thank you
notes comedy poetry
just a life of a writer in 2021 i'm
going to regulate that
which means i'm going to dedicate part
of my day every day to
the craft of writing i'm going to live
the life
of someone who writes and underneath
that is going to be all kinds of
goals and ideas but the main arc of that
is going to be i'm going to live the
life of a writer and you know what the
next
book is going to take care of itself the
next speech is going to take care of
itself because i'm going to get in the
habit and the practice of being somebody
who writes
the next one is i had a new job this
year this it's my first year
to work in radio to work and podcasting
and all that shenanigans
i have a new job as a radio host a
podcast host speaker writer my goal is
not to have a bunch of followers
to get a bunch of talks to get a bunch
of new whatevers
my goal is to be become to continue to
become a world-class communicator
that's different right because i could
have my goal is to have 30 speeches i
could get 30 speeches
and not be any better at it not
listening to feedback not
growing any just taking a job because
it's a job because it's going to get me
my check off list
no i want to be a world-class
communicator what does that mean
i'm going to work with writers i want to
learn how to do what i do better
i'm going to work with the videographers
we're gonna go back and watch videos
you wanna do something awkward give a
speech and then get with a team of
people and break it down
and they ask things like why are you
standing like that why'd you say that
that wasn't even funny
look how your face looks right we're
gonna get with
leadership here on the playback right
i'm going to get into the craft of
communicating i'm going to continue to
study stand-up comedians
musicians people who are professional
communicators
across multiple different platforms and
then i'm going to continue to speak and
perform and stretch where i can
but the goal is to become a world-class
communicator not just to get a bunch of
metrics and a bunch of numbers the
metrics and numbers should take care of
themselves
if i become a world-class communicator
if i put in the hard hard work
the humbling humbling vulnerable work
right
my goal is to steward my body so on
january 7th i'm going to start a no
sugar challenge i'm going to invite all
you guys to do that i'll be
talking about this in a later show and
we'll be talking about it on
the social medias but i gotta quit
eating sugar guys
the the i i've come far enough in my
life that i can't deny the research
that sugar contributes to every
single decline in the human body it's
just falling apart
um it's killing us from the inside out
it's killing us from the outside in it's
just bad i gotta stop
and i also have to be graceful with
myself when my daughter has a birthday
party when my son has a birthday party
when i have a birthday party i'm gonna
have a piece of cake
because i'm also a human being too i'm
gonna work out i'm gonna walk i'm gonna
play i'm gonna make
movement a priority i'm also as a part
of being a steward of my body i'm gonna
go to a dentist for the first time and
oh geez
i'm gonna get real blood work done again
and actually sit down with somebody and
go through it
i've been ignoring that for the last few
seasons
i'm gonna really re-double my focus on
sleep and make that a
new numero uno or dose and one or two
priorities in my life sleep first and
everything else will come from that
i'm gonna have a goal of being a steward
of my mind
and so instead of saying i'm gonna read
42 books i'm gonna read a book every
week no
i'm gonna read and that's gonna include
books that's going to include
good essays it's going to become include
science articles
i'm also going to get into something i
haven't done for a long time and that is
some of the advancements in science tech
i want to get and see some of these
things you can actually watch blood
interactions
you can actually get on the internet and
these extraordinary
doctors and research scientists and
medical researchers
have done some really extraordinary work
with animators you can actually go down
into the human body and see how some of
these things work
it's a biology textbook that has come
alive and those things are fun for me
i also want to learn i got chickens and
sheep and i want to
get get some bees right i want to learn
how to do some things outside that i've
been talking about for years
i've got a massive massive garden me and
my wife and my kids are working on
i want to learn how to do some of the
home repair things that i've had to pay
out over the years i'm gonna actually
learn how to do it
and then i'm gonna pick up the guitar
i've been playing guitar for 30 years or
so i want to pick it back up
and start practicing more regularly but
that all that comes back to want to be
somebody
who is a steward of their mind who
learns new things i want to continue
meeting and learning from mental health
professionals
and i have some transitional theology
questions that i've been rattling around
for the last year or two
that are powerful and really faith
shifting for me in a really
extraordinary way
and so i'm going to spend some time
answering those both experientially both
sitting down with
people who know way more about those
things than i do and through
reading and continuing to delve into
spiritual and faith issues and so
um the final one is i'm going to be a
steward of my relationships
i'm going to continue to invest in my
wife continue to invest in my kids
continue to invest in my friendships
i got lonely this year like we all did
but i got lonely this year and i've got
to redouble my
efforts on being somebody who invests in
friendships investing in my local church
and that starts tomorrow when my wife
and i go on our annual retreat we talk
about
what we liked about this year what we
didn't like about this year we go to
some coffee shops around town this year
some of them may be closed so we may be
out walking around at different parks or
different hikes or whatever that may
look like but we're going to spend some
time being intentional about being
reflective over last year
what do we want this year to look like
and how loosely are we going to hold
those things because who knows what 2021
holds for us
so make sure you write these things down
the goal here being this as much as it's
been fun to say
god almighty i can't wait till 2020 is
over 2021 may be worse
probably not but maybe
and so given those two realities
probably not but maybe
all you can control is you your thoughts
your actions
your heart your relationships that's it
so write down who you want to be
write down the kind of person you want
to become
who are you going to be
write them down get somebody in your
life that's going to hold you
accountable and then let's go get it man
let's have an extraordinary year